new Jurassic Park looks awesome I don't
know why everyone was complaining about
all the visual effects I think it looks
great
that's a Pixar movie really I think it
looks better than Jurassic world ever
anymore and there's a lot of confusion
about with Nic ding dong dinosaur what's
it called the good dinosaur good
dinosaur there's a lot of confusion
about what's it called and obviously
what's it about
are there dinosaurs in it we've got the
inside scoop this is hashtag news the
good dinosaurs Pixar's 16th future film
and it basically tackles the question
about what if the creationists were
right dinos people living together cool
basically if the asteroid didn't hit the
earth 55 million years ago when
dinosaurs grew up to be like us talk
they've society some are nice some are
mean summer vegans the teaser doesn't
show too much but we do get a couple
shots of dinosaurs and humans
interacting like a boy riding on top of
a young Knapp Apatosaurus Apatosaurus
Judd Apatow Soros he's middle-aged he
makes too many romantic comedies hey
this is 48 million years ago
roasted that dinosaur is named Arlo and
the boy is named spot lots of dogs named
get real might Alaska their Pixar I
think that people should have people
names and dinosaurs should have dinosaur
names like dragon boy like dragon boy in
the movie the dinosaur Arlo falls into a
river typical dinosaurs and he ends up
befriending spot the human and he helps
him find his way home we've been in a
Pixar drought but this year the rain is
coming and inside out comes out on June
19th three days before my birthday
and good data comes out November I'm
really excited about this movie because
it boasts some of the funniest people in
the biz Neil Patrick Harris well here
Judy Greer Frances McDorman and John
Lithgow it's just because it's a Pixar
movie doesn't mean it doesn't have some
new drama around it so I've heard tell
anybody this is on the Internet Bob
Pearson was directing I may know him
better as the voice of Doug and my name
is Doug I have just met you and I'd love
for Roz and Monsters Inc that's right
it's a boy I say was because he was
fired because rumor he couldn't figure
out the film's ending that's weird
shouldn't it be in the script maybe he
didn't read the script but I guess he's
still buddy-buddy with Pixar because
he's still working there I'm sure it's
on the next vehicle movie we give you
bullets I love it originally the film
was delayed a whole year and jonatha had
to rerecord this whole part in the movie
he said that it was dismantled and
completely reimagined although what told
us not to worry saying it's gonna be
better than he ever imagined John
Lithgow was it we've already seen some
Easter eggs like a few of these dinos
were in monsters University and not to
mention the Dinoco gas company which is
pretty much in every Pixar's movie so
I'm really excited clearly about Pixar's
the good dinosaur I'm excited to see
which dinosaurs the good dinosaur maybe
it's not the lead dinosaur maybe he's
kind of an uncle
we'll find out November tell me what you
think like and subscribe if you like
dinosaurs tell me what your favorite
dinosaur is did you know I can make a
pterodactyl noise it goes like this
makes I'm gonna terrify you are you
watching are you watching this video
right now subscribe you think you just
got it click button below see more of
this face
Oh anymore and if you like the idea of
dinosaurs and humans living together
call me if you're a dinosaur cuz I'm
looking for a new roommate fencers watch
YouTube right
[Music]